mais ça y est il est commandé au bar
notre cocktail il est en préparation
notre duo de choc aujourd'hui c'est
deborah cnes et les nids de la coûte
alors aujourd'hui on va vous présenter
le cocktail sans alcool le florida
ananas donc le floride ananas pour deux
cocktails
il nous faudra du jus d'ananas 8
centilitres 810 litres de jus d'orange
qu'as tu ressenti litres de jus de
citron
fraîchement pressé et un trait de
grenadine donc pour commencer nous
allons livrer les verts alors givre et
les verts c'est une base de sirop pour
mais dans une soucoupe avec une base de
sucre
[Musique]
et du coup ça nous fait une décoration
ensuite on va commencer par glace et le
shaker avec des glaçons à peu près un
quart du shaker donc on prend toujours
une pince à glaçons
[Musique]
aux réserves et on commence à presser le
citron 1 demi-citron c'est à peu près
200 6 litres de jus de citron
donc là on va faire du coup le citron
entier pour 4 centilitres
donc pour doser on utilise un doseur ok
donc ici vous avez 4 centilitres ici
vous avez deux centilitres donc là les
nids va faire 4 centilitres de jus de
citron
et après il va les mettre directement
dans le shaker
[Musique]
ce
ensuite il va faire 800 thil et de jus
d'ananas et 806 litres de jus d'orange
donc du coup il faudra qu'ils mettent
deux doses
même chose pour le jus d'orange 8
centilitres ensuite il referme son
shaker et il commence donc à checker
donc à une façon de checker eni va vous
montrer comment fait on fait de autant
bas pendant environ 10 à 15 secondes
on ouvre le shaker on utilise la
passoire à cocktail
du coup qui permet de retenir les
glaçons
[Musique]
et après on va verser dans le vert
donc le cocktail est pratiquement
terminé on va rajouter un trait de
grenadine donc le 13 grenadines on peut
très bien le mettre directement dans le
shaker
sauf que là pour qu'ils aient une petite
décoration et notamment quand vous voyez
un trait de sirop au fond du verre en
fait yens technique on utilise une
cuillère à café le la cuire sur le
rebord du verre et après vous faites
couler votre votre produit
et pour terminer on met deux brochettes
de décoration
et le cocktail est prêt à être dégusté
merci beaucoup à tous les deux
effectivement je vois bien juste en
dessous la grenadine qui est allé se
placer pile comme il fallait
merci beaucoup à la vôtre les amis